All spruced up and ready for a new
tenant. The Waimakariri District Council
has recently renovated two of its
pensioner housing units as part of a
pilot scheme.  It's more than just a lick
of paint the remodeled units boast
new carpet, kitchens, laundries and double glazing throughout.
Some even have dedicated
parking and charging spots for mobility scooters.
I think it's very impressive
and it's in modern colors and it looks warm
and inviting. It's really good to see
this upgrade
Not only are they more attractive, Jean Gouedard from the Council's property team says the newly improved
units will save tenants money on their
power bill and be healthier to live in.
We are really encouraging our residents
to have healthier living and with the
insulation and all the functionality of
the kitchen and everything, we hope that
they'll have nicer living conditions and you'd be proud to have anyone here.
These units are part of
the Council's pensioner housing
facility in Kaiapoi's Martyn Place and
were first built in the late 60s.
They were due for a makeover
however originally only the kitchens
were going to be replaced.
Because we needed the removal of asbestos, it was a
good idea to do more than just the
kitchen fit out so that we could update
all the insulation throughout including
double glazing for windows and doors.
Modern building code requirements mean
that the units require reinvestment
if they're to remain safe and functional for
the next 50 years. If the pilot scheme is
successful and approved by Council as
part of the Long Term Plan,
similar improvements will be rolled out for Council pensioner housing district-wide.
That would require a rental increase for
tenants, however this would largely be
offset by government housing subsidies
and reduced energy and medical bills.
We've got over a hundred units across
Woodend, Oxford, Rangiora and Kaiapoi
and most of them are fairly old and so
refurbishing them and bringing them up to
modern standards, I think is very
important for the residents.
Council will be considering the plan later this year and if approved, the renovations
will be rolled out over the next five to
ten years